how did you spend your first few years
as an actor and then how do you spend
them now good question my first few
years as an actor was hard worked it was
some you know I told my actors the story
about eating eggs water and donuts but
making sure I had money for my acting
class I didn't have a car but I would
take the bus to get there didn't know
how I would get home but God blessed me
with someone who would give me a ride it
was all about just being the best that I
could possibly be I wanted to be in the
ranks of the leading men of my caliber
Denzel wesley snipes Cooper Gooding
those were the scenes I worked on and I
knew who I was as an actor and I worked
towards playing those authoritative
roles I didn't have a problem playing
thugs or you know gangbangers just I
loved those characters those the guys I
grew up with so I understand it but I've
never been jaded in a sense of like not
having the opportunity play certain
roles look listen in my beginning of an
act as being an actor I worked on as
many roles as I possibly could if the
roles didn't exist I wrote him and I
would bring him into class and so for me
it was just being the best that I
possibly could be to understand the
process of acting and to be great at it
and to be a joy to be around because I
understood that's how people continue to
work with you where I'm at now as an
actor I really don't care for the
auditioning process I don't care for I
do it my managers always on me about it
so I do it I go in one of the things
that make made me not care for it is
knowing the politics behind it because
I'm a producer and a director now I know
what I didn't know back then when I was
just acting and that is sometimes even
if you're auditioning for a role you're
already not gonna get it because they
may be on the phone talking to the
person that they just offered the role
to so that's kind of tough and where I'm
at now I create my own content I direct
I write and I have people who call me up
and put me in projects because they
remembered me
an actor and they remember my work so it
can be a little funny sometimes for me
because it's like I listen do I really
want to waste the time an audition for
something that I may not get or you know
do I just continue to do the process
because that's what that is is audition
it's part of the acting process yeah I
don't know where I'm at now I just love
having something that I write or someone
write for me and say hey this come do
this it's easier there's no pressures no
stress about it and I enjoy that a
little bit more than yeah I've never
been a competitive person even in the
martial arts you know the fight in
tournaments wasn't for me so with acting
I don't look at his competition I look
at it like I said it's love they can't
be competition in love so I if if the
role is right for me give it to me I'll
show up for you and I'll do a great job
you think that audition grind is what
sends a lot of people home or somewhere
else somewhat I think what sends people
home mostly is lack of money people get
into the entertainment industry thinking
that they're gonna make a lot of money
and I always tell actors if you got into
the entertainment industry to make money
you can do anything else I mean you can
do porn and make a lot of money
relationship for some people because you
know they may have got out of college or
they left a corporate job or they left
pharmaceuticals I knew an actor who was
a rocket scientist but he wasn't happy
unless he was doing acting and they get
into the acting world and they want to
make a lot of money in two three years
go by four years maybe five and they're
not making any money they're working a
dead-end job and they start to battle
with that and so I think typically
that's usually what sends people home
the auditioning process has a different
experience when you hear these stories
of like Angelina Jolie or Mark Ruffalo
they said he went out fifty times and so
he got his first role I I believe that
everybody's resilience is a different
level I didn't have to go
50 times I think I went out three times
and I booked my third audition I didn't
yeah I was that type of actor um
but I could see how the the rejection
because like I said everybody's looking
for love and even if you were going out
for somebody that you you like or you're
attracted to and you get that rejection
is it there's a thing you go through
there's a catharsis this it's a hurtful
period you go through and I think if
you're going out for auditions and you
may be right for them and you're being
told no no and no you start to question
yourself is this right for me is this
really what I should be doing listen if
we're all climbing up a mountain we
don't know what's at the top of the
mountain till we get there the climb is
just part of the journey
auditions are just part of the journey
and I believe that I do believe that
there's a point where actors need to
know if they are auditioning actors or
not which basically means this if you go
in and you cannot defeat the nervousness
maybe audition is not for you unless it
helps you to book the audition maybe be
a nervous books that audition maybe you
go in you feel like you did a horrible
job and then you get the callback and
you book it like I was horrible that
happens but I do believe that there's a
sense that actors need to know if they
are auditioning actors is the
auditioning process for you and if it
isn't what adjustment are you willing to
make in order to be great at it so that
way you're not missing out on
opportunities or you're not wasting your
time
you